welcome to the vibrant world of Linux
Mint where Innovation and accessibility
blend seamlessly as we delve into this
operating system it's inging to note
that Linux Mint has been rapidly
climbing the ranks in the world of
open-source software did you know that
as of 2023 Linux Mint holds a
significant share in the Linux desktop
Market standing out amongst hundreds of
distributions it's not just its
userfriendly interface that's catching
eyes statistics show a consistent
increase in downloads with millions of
users worldwide embracing its refreshing
Simplicity and robust performance Linux
melt a brainchild born from robust ubu
is celebrated for its elegance and
efficiency it is particularly favored by
those transitioning from other operating
systems owing to its similar layout and
intuitive Design This OS isn't just
about its look performance metrics
reveal a lightweight yet powerful system
capable of Reviving or older hardware
and providing a smooth experience on the
latest machines as we explore Linux Mint
we will uncover why it has become a Top
Choice for both noise and Tech
professionals from its customization
capabilities to its community-driven
development Linux Mint isn't just an
operating system it's a movement a
movement towards a more accessible
reliable and user Centric Computing
future so let's embark on this minty
journey and unwrap the many layers of
this Innovative and peppermint power
and before commencing just a quick info
for you if you're an aspiring cyber
security professional looking for online
training and certifications from
prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts to
enhance your credibility then search no
more simply learn postgraduate program
in cyber security from MIT University in
collaboration with EC Council should be
your right choice through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like Advanced
hacking Concepts Network packet analysis
ethical hacking network security and
over a dozen others and that's not all
you also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in top tier
product and security companies and
academicians from top
universities this course is designed to
accommodate a diverse range of Learners
and this course requires just a
bachelor's degree with a 50% of average
and no prior programming experience is
required and 1 plus year of work
experience is preferred if you are
passionate about making your career in
this field then make sure to check out
the link in the pin commment and
description box to find a cyber security
program that will fit your experience
and area of Interest so now moving on to
the demo part and here first we'll see
the Linux Mint website and do you know
that Linux Mint has three versions so
first we'll click on download and here
you can see the first version is cinemon
Edition and then mate Edition and xfc
Edition so cineman Edition is the
popular version of reux M and is
primarily developed for and by Linux
Mint only like it is Sleek beautiful and
full of features it has many features
and we'll have a demo session for that
only where we will see the features of
cinemon version and then we have the
matte Edition that is for stable robust
and traditional purposes and then we
have xfc version that is extremely
stable and very light on resource usage
so I have installed the cinamon Edition
and that to on the Oracle virtual box so
if you want to install it you can either
boot a pen drive and install it as your
main operating system as I was running
Windows and for this demo I have
installed this so I have installed it on
the virtual box so here we'll start with
the demo for the cinamon Edition so the
first thing we'll see is first thing
we'll go for his preferences and the
display option so here in the the
display option you can set the
resolution for your cin Edition Linux
Min
like which resolution you want so I will
set this and if you want the rotation
for your display screen you can do that
so this was one of the feature and
moving on in preferences only we have
one more that is we'll see what we have
yeah we have a accessibility also so in
accessibility you could either do the
large text or the smaller text you could
do for the high contrast enable Zoom you
could move to keyboard and use visual
indicator on caps and numlock so these
are the things you could do and yeah uh
like there was text size increase or the
enhancement option we can also do with
the font selection for that will go
preferences in preferences
only uh there would be one phone
selection one yeah here you could just
select the default font also okay which
font you want and the size of the
default font so you could select that
for the desktop font document font
monospace window title and the text
scaling Factor so we could enlarge it
according to your
requirements and now moving to other
options and preferences only we'll
see so we have Mouse and
touchpad so in Mouse and touchpad you
could just adjust the pointer size you
could see the pointer size here pointer
speed pointer size and accordingly we
have other options if you have operated
on any of the operating system you would
easily have a catch on it so I'll will
show you where all the like settings and
all the things you could get on so in
preferences only or we could just
customize this panel we can just right
click on it and go to panel settings and
you could see the font size for the left
zone so this is the left Zone allow them
to determine font size and scale to or
we can just increase the icon size here
or if we go to the right zone so the
icon size will increase for these as you
can
see so this is how you could assess all
these and if you want to change the
desktop background you could easily do
it you just have to right click it and
click on change desktop
background and you could have any
pictures you want as I have the default
ones I will use this one so you could
see that the desktop has been
changed and
now uh yeah I want to tell you that
these settings would be changed after
you reboot the system so all the
settings will be lost so now we will go
to accessories and if you want any app
on the like this navigation bar or on
the desktop you could just right click
on that app and add to panel so you
could see here it has been added to
panel and you could also unpin from
panel also we have unpinned it and in
accessories like calculator only if you
want it on desktop you could add it on
desktop so it's on desktop now so
similarly you could add any app here and
now if you want to configure menu just
right click on the menu and there's a
configure
option and here you could configure it
if you want to increase the size in in
the menu you could do that if you want
to change any text or add any text you
would do that and if you use want to use
any menu animation you can do that so
these are the features of Linux Mint and
if you want to capture snapshot then you
will go to
administrator and then there's a option
with time
shift and it will require your password
so for that we will enter the password
so you could create any snap short here
and you could have recurrent ones also
using the wizard
option and now we'll see the driver
manager and that's also in the
administrator section so driver manager
so it will show you what are the drivers
installed on your
system so it shows that no driver your
computer does not need any additional
drivers so this was all for this
tutorial hope you guys found it
informative and helpful as we have
covered many preferences and many
options for the Linux M so you could get
a easy handon so if you're like shifting
from any OS to Linux Mint so this
tutorial would help you out that and if
you guys found this tutorial informative
and helpful then please subscribe share
and like the video Until then stay safe
and keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here